welcome to best life 30 your 30-day
journey to creating the best life
possible for yourself you can just watch
this video or can sign up for free and
get the bonus companion worksheets that
go along with each video by checking the
link down in the description below
alright today is day 28 and we're gonna
learn how to be a better leader I've
spent so much of the past 20 years of my
life evangelizing a message that
leadership is not about a title
leadership is not about the size of your
office leadership is not about having
formal Authority leadership is a mindset
leadership is a way of operating through
your days leadership is a heart set
leadership is a way of being and I think
you know we're now in leadership 2.0 the
old model of leadership said you need to
have a lot of money or you need to be a
prime minister or President you need to
be a CEO or managing director in order
to be a leader leadership 2.0 is
fundamentally different leadership 2.0
simply says if you can breathe if you
are alive you not only have the
opportunity you have the responsibility
to show leadership not only in your work
not only in your creativity not only in
your impact not only in your influence
but even in your personal life and so
what I want to do in this mastery
session I'm thrilled that you're here
with me today so let's get right to the
first tactic for you to be an even
better leader install the lead without a
title mindset and again that's just a
way of thinking it's an approach so what
I'm really suggesting is no matter what
you do no matter what your station in
life is start thinking like a leader
because you really have a choice when
you go out in the world everyday you can
be a victim or you can be a leader but
you can't do both and so the more you
practice showing leadership in your work
showing leadership with your family
showing leadership in your community
showing leadership in your private self
practice drives performance and the more
you practice it the more you start to
step into the mindset of a leader
without a title number two the best
leaders on the planet
other leaders so if you're not growing
leaders faster than your peers you're
not leading your following I'm gonna
repeat that again the job of the leader
is to grow more leaders so yes do your
work
yes become more creative yes innovate
yes optimize your personal life and yet
at the same time make the time to
develop leaders around you what that
might look like at the office
celebrating a teammate at the office
that might look like modeling mastery at
the office it might look like
collaborating with someone who needs
some collaboration at home
what does growing leaders look like well
it might be mentoring your children
exposing them to art giving them great
books it might mean being a positive
force in your home life
so the job of the leader is to grow more
leaders one of the keys to Apple is
apples an incredibly collaborative
company and so you know how many
committees we have at Apple no zero at
no committees no committee we are there
we are organized like a startup one
person is in charge of iPhone OS
software one person is in charge of Mac
hardware one person is in charge of
iPhone hardware engineering another
person is in charge of worldwide
marketing another person is in charge of
operations
it's we're organized like a start-up
we're the biggest startup on the planet
and we all meet for three hours once a
week and we talk about everything we're
doing the whole business and there's
tremendous teamwork at the top of the
company which filters down to tremendous
teamwork throughout the company and
teamwork is dependent on trusting the
other folks to come through with their
part without watching them all the time
but trusting that they're going to come
through with their parts and that's what
we do really well and we're great at
figuring out how to divide things up
into these great teams that we have and
all work on the same
touch bases frequently and bring it all
together into a product we do that
really well and so what I do all day is
meet with teams of people and work on
ideas and solve problems to make new
products to make new marketing programs
whatever it is and our people willing to
tell you you're wrong yeah I mean other
than snarky journalists I mean people
are ya know we have wonderful arguments
and do you win them all or oh no I wish
I did
no see you can't if you want to hire
great people and have them stay working
for you you have to let them make a lot
of decisions and you have to you have to
be run by ideas not hierarchy the best
ideas have to win so otherwise good
people don't stay how could we
you can't you can't you can't what you
can do is you can hustle and then people
will either ride up to it or run away
from it like you know I don't judge my
people first of all nobody that works
for you should hustle as hard as you
period you want somebody to hustle as
hard as you that works for you give them
the same economics you're taking home
that's excuse number two with kids rich
kids aren't gonna care as much as you
about money because you didn't have any
and so you had a fight for it and then
that's just real so I think you said I
set the tone for my company some people
rise up some people find their work-life
balance some people bounce I'm not in
the game of thinking that's important if
I feel good about what I'm paying
somebody for for what I'm getting in
return I don't need to judge that they
need to work harder so I don't want to
get a deal for my people do you
understand I want mighty people to be on
my team not me getting more value out of
them it's a huge mistake of business
owners my number one belief about
leadership is you're a servant here's
what I mean here's what I mean
specifically the word hero hero that
isn't the archetype of like men and you
and I bet it's my is it true that inside
of you you want you wouldn't want to be
the best you want to create the best
share the best do the best is that is
that a metaphor for you in your life
absolutely yeah me too
so I think people in this room tend to
have that as their metaphor so all of us
at some level man or woman wants to be
hero the word hero if latin root means
servo servo means servant it actually
means slave the hero why they're the
hero has become the ultimate servant to
something larger than themselves people
and so forth the person who thinks
they're gonna lead by demand or by
position can only leave for a short
period of time but the person whose idea
serving as my belief is if you can find
a way to take any group of people and
help them to experience their needs at a
richer deeper level than anyone else
then together you guys can get anything
done
anything now it may not work the first
time but together you can get to that
point because needs are ultimately we're
after we're not after the vehicle we
think Raptor you want a billion dollars
then you get it I got plenty clients and
I will tell you it is not the end game
and so now if then they go off to their
second billion or or you think it's
getting married and then you get it he
find out it's not the end game for
certain needs that have to be there and
the ultimate needs are growing and
giving because you only can feel so good
filled up by yourself so my core belief
is I got a serve if I serve I can lead
because I believe motive does matter if
my motive is just to get you to do
something for me there's a certain
amount of power that I can get to do
that if I strategize if I think if I
feel and also if it serves a greater
good even if I don't intend it if the
bumblebee goes to try to get the nectar
it wants it's selfish goal I believe is
a higher power the guys at all and when
that bumblebee goes it doesn't intend to
give anything but pollen sticks to its
legs as it goes about trying to get what
it wants that's how flowers are created
I really believe that everything has a
web of connection if your intent is to
serve yourself you're still going to
serve something more than yourself and
you're going to get a certain amount of
insight if your intent in your motive is
to serve something yourself but also
something more just your kids then I
believe you get a different level of
insight and because you're serving more
of what serves life it's not just me
it's me and my family if you're trying
to serve a community I believe you get a
different level of insight the furnisher
of humanity you get a difference I get
emotional thing about this is why I do
what I do so when someone stands up it's
not about business it's not about
anything but about serving them so I
will use abrasive or creative language
I'll use whatever it takes humor stupid
I'll make fun of myself I'll challenge
I'll do anything to serve that's why I'm
here I don't need to do more but I love
to see someone free and alive and lit up
so when that's your motive no matter how
people perceiving it outside if they're
around you long enough
you can't hide what your real motive is
and they'll see it and they'll feel it
motive does matter if it's to serve
something high it'll be that that
doesn't mean you don't get served too
and in business you got to be served or
I used to do business and I lose money
in the business everybody else was happy
and it was wonderful except I had no
business so it's you know killing the
goose that lays the golden eggs so I've
learned to put that balance in but that
gives me power that's why time
disappears for me because I'm not about
getting some action done I'm about the
outcome my first job out of college I
had a boss who believed it was
appropriate to berate people to get the
most out of them and I remember this is
a true story I actually sat down with
her we used to have these sort of
monthly career updates you know and she
literally said to me you have no talent
quote unquote and I went none and she
said none you know and the good news was
I thought that was funny because she
kind of none like if you told me I only
could do one thing that actually public
more but nothing you know nothing and so
I really paid attention as to how she
managed and the rest of my career did
the complete opposite yeah give me an
example I book you know I think that
pointing out people's strengths is a lot
better than telling them they have no
talent also she had this belief that if
you don't look harried and insane then
you then you might then you're not
working hard you know so I remember
pretending that I was like stressed out
because if I sauntered down the hallway
and said hi to people she thought I was
doing nothing right so I started
pretending it's like I can talk I can
talk and that way she thought I was very
busy and she left me alone yeah honesty
in management you know treating people
with respect being honest about what
they they can and can't do and
committing yourself to helping people
not not hurting people or pushing them
down has been more effective for me
sometimes at work it's not what's
happening it worked for a lot of
stressed out managers especially it's
what's happening outside of work how do
you try to figure out where the sources
of the issue may be to cut past some of
the challenges you face communicating
when I was entry-level having empathy
from
boss didn't factor in you know not
knowing anything about sort of my place
and then in the company of etc but as
I've as I've grown up I realized that
the only motivation for any kind of
confrontation whether you're the one
who's confronting someone because you
feel that they have done something wrong
or whether you're confronting them
because you feel that you've been
wronged you know the only the only
motivation is empathy and so even if
someone has is coming down on me hard or
being unreasonable or being you know
I've I'm not perfect at it but I've
worked really hard to approach it with
you you know confronting them that
they've hurt me or it so that I feel
wronged but but immediately go into the
considering that maybe there's something
that's bothering them and and that has
proved to be really helpful and and we
do it in in life I mean for example you
know somebody sitting next to you on the
subway is you know slouched back their
legs open and your immediate sort of
reaction is to think what an ass you
know but the idea of practicing and say
well maybe he had a hard day less like
yesterday and he's exhausted and he just
doesn't want to deal you know maybe he
doesn't want to talk to people you know
and and so to to really just sort of
have empathy for the world around you
it's it's kind of powerful and people
respond to you a lot better as well
because basically everybody wants to
feel safe and so if you have empathy you
you you give that to people up or down
the chain of command I mean we we as
employees want to feel safe and those
are bosses responsibility to give us
that but at the same time bosses want to
feel safe they don't want to feel that
there's insurrection you know that
that's brewing and and for us to let
them know that we've got their back as
much as we want them to let us know that
they have ours is equally as important
and I believe there is responsibilities
of a manager but there's a
responsibility of an employee as well
you know it's like the kids have to do
chores at home you know it's the kind of
same thing it's like we all it takes all
of us yeah the hierarchy doesn't doesn't
mean that only the guys above are the
ones with responsibility we all we all
have to contribute it's not that we need
more female leaders it's that we need
more leaders to act like females
women just happen to be better at that
you know traditionally male
characteristics like aggression or
decisiveness there's only one part of
leadership but there are traditionally
feminine or female characteristics like
patience like caring like a maternal
instinct you know that are extremely
important if not essential to good
leadership
so the problem in America today if not
the world is we have lopsided leadership
we've over we put too much emphasis on
male leadership and we need to balance
it off and the best leaders whether
they're male or female embody patience
and calm and and and and caring and that
motherly instinct or fatherly instinct
like you know that that parenting
instinct and so we need it more balanced
oh absolutely we need more more female
leaders but we need them to act like
females we don't want them to act like
men I don't want women who are decisive
and aggressive I want women who are
caring and patient and all of that good
stuff I want men like that too
so yes we definitely need more female
leadership what did you know and learn
at the end of your career that you wish
you knew at the beginning understanding
empathy and compassion because as a
young kid when I came in the league it
was like I'm driving this way and either
you're gonna be on the train or be on
the track but there was no such thing as
understanding that people have lives
outside of the Genki which apparently I
did not but like if I understood at an
early age and I'm it helps me as a
leader to communicate better I came to
understand that later and getting to
know people on a personal level whether
their fears where their insecurities
where their dreams and ambitions desires
those sorts of things you come to
understand that about a person then you
can help them reach the best version of
themselves so I wish I'd known that
earlier I want people to that I mentor
to do better than me so if you're in
this thing we're like that you want
people to do well around
you need to do better than them you're
really not leading people so leadership
is really simple here's how you lead
somebody every human being just even
like what you're just describing
yourself is born with their natural
giftedness if your person of faith I
believe it was sewn into you but if you
just you could just call your talent you
don't have faith so for example it could
be your ability to communicate your
heart your spirit your nurturing skills
your engineering skills your math skills
your discipline right your whatever it
is you were born with natural giftedness
here's what a great leader does and it's
you'll be one of the rarest people on
earth if you can do this for people just
get quiet and observe people as a leader
and when you can identify what someone's
two or three natural gifts are and
they're things they know intuitively to
be true about themselves and you link
that gift to them achieving you've built
a leader as if I said to you it's your
natural heart to serve people brother
it's your unbelievable ability to
communicate it's your mom and our
background in your ear that whole time
supporting you given you link that's
what you're gonna change the world and
you go that I do have a great mom I do
have a heart to serve I do have a big
spirit and you link that to them boom
because here's the truth in life those
either are listening on one hand if
you're lucky probably there's one or two
fingers you can count the person who
that when you're a little boy or a
little girl made you feel special knew
you were special
remember them just picture their face
right now you know exactly what I'm
talking about
maybe it's your mother or a coach or
your grandpa or an uncle or an auntie
and that's the one when you're a little
boy or girl they made you feel special
they knew you were different they knew
you reading they saw your blessings they
saw your gifts maybe you got one in your
life and when you picture their face
whether they've passed away or still
living you get emotional you can picture
the times they made you feel that way
can't you write okay if you're a great
leader you end up on that hand of
thousands of people so in my life I want
to be that person one of them may
picture in my life
ed my let was this guy who saw how
special I was he saw my gifts he saw my
blessings he told me over and over again
how blessed and gifted I am and he
linked that to me winning it wasn't some
rah-rah you're gonna do great man you're
a champion go go go
it was deep he would touch me in my
spirit he found my gift and my blessing
and when you're that person you will be
on the hands of someone in their life
one or two places three places of their
entire life that's what a great leader
does what's your philosophy when it
comes to human resources how do you get
the right people and then how do you
keep the right people that's the most
important part of business you know
that's why I went to military school
and I went to I was a Marine Corps the
reason why when I talk to military
veterans you probably have the most
important skill of all because all we're
trained to do whether you're as a
general or a private you're taught to be
leaders it is a number one skill of an
entrepreneur is people skills and
leadership skills and unfortunately most
people don't have it coming into so when
I do my talks to veterans and all the
stuff I really want to encourage them
because if they're pretty depressed
because they can't get it you know
they're a long march greeter which is a
good job but they're afraid to take the
leap into entrepreneurship so but
military guys I don't care what branch
of service just by the indoctrination
process and the survival rate where they
go to combat or not is that you learn
leadership skills people skills you've
got to have that you know whether
whether you're a team of one you still
have to deal your customers and the good
customers bad customers lawsuits taxes
government regulations and all this
they're all people skills you know so
when somebody says to me what do I need
to learn I said boy you'd better learn
how to communicate pretty quickly to
people you don't like and get them on
your side you know how to win friends
and influence people basic book the
number one skill of an entrepreneur is
people skills
you know who you have control over you
you know if control you don't have
control over your nine year old kid you
might think you do but you don't you got
to make you know if control over your
wife to just make her you know get in
the game oh you wanted you want to stay
on the program you want to cook whatever
14 chicken breasts on a Sunday night so
you got to a day during the week honey
make it happen know
honey don't make that happen
if you are a good leader and you explain
what your goals are and you get her on
board with the program hmm then yeah
guess what she's doing on Sunday night
helping you cook some chicken breasts
for the week yeah but this is just like
anything else man this is just like any
other leadership situation you want to
blame the team when something's going
wrong that's not gonna get you a
solution you need to take ownership of
the problem you need to get the problem
solved and when I say get the problem
solved
you're you this doesn't mean impose your
will on the team that means you need to
lead the team and there's a big
difference what are some of the
Telltale's that you have seen over your
years that tell you this person isn't
right I have to let her or him go that's
a good question and I'll answer it with
an analogy of fact I carry two phones
with me this small one is only known by
my family and very very close friends
and when it rings I'll always answer it
because it has to do with something
going on with my kids or my family or my
brother or whatever this phone this
larger one probably 10,000 people have
this number I'm a believer that if you
are an entrepreneur or a major
shareholder of a company every single
customer should know if they have a
problem who they can call and when I say
this this concept of access in other
words many managers think well you know
if I give my number out to my employees
they may call me and and the truth is
you want to hear from them you want to
hear the bad news first what I found is
the more people I give this number to
the less it rings I tell them simply
look I want you to have this access
because I respect you and I want you to
know that you can come to me and in that
trust I find that most people never use
it if this thing does not ring as much
as my family for
but when it rings it's a big deal and
the reason I know it's time to terminate
somebody in one of my companies is when
my customers and my shareholders call me
three times about that person hmm it's
always the same mm-hmm it's always the
same when a customer's complaining about
a CEO or a head of sales or the head of
R&D or employees are not happy and I
keep getting that phone call I get on
the plane and I get my whack and stick
out because there's something wrong so
the leadership is not about personality
is sure in fact some of the greatest
leaders we studied had a charisma bypass
and we should never confuse charisma
with leadership they're very very
different ideas some of them are even
odd and eccentric one of the great chief
executives of the last 30 years is Herb
Kelleher of Southwest Airlines he solves
a trademark dispute with an
arm-wrestling contest it's just not
normal he would talk about wearing a
flowered hat and a feathered boa around
the office just strange this is not
personality the key to the great leaders
that we studied was their humility
but it was humility of a very special
type it wasn't humility in just in a
weak sense it was in fact just the
opposite it was what I would describe as
an absolute obsessed burning compulsive
ambition that wasn't about them an
absolute burning compulsive ambition for
cause for a company for the work for a
set of values not themselves an ability
to translate that ambition that
subjugating themselves to something that
is not about them into a series of
decisions very willful decisions and
this is why I look to Lincoln as our
great president in the United States
because he was ambitious first and
foremost that the nation must endure and
he had the will to endure the most
brutal war in all of our history
with all of it during his tenure and to
lose his life I think building an
organization building a team
the idea that Jack Welch is the hero of
creating all this value is silly getting
great people in all these jobs it's a
team that makes this thing happen and so
building a team is your strongest suit
and you've got to love your team you
don't want your team to be promoted and
when you're coming up the biggest
problem I find with young MBAs at first
the job is you shining raising your hand
having the answers they want to do that
all the time they just go to school they
want to show you how smart they are now
the transition to manager it all changes
it's about growing your people not you
you grow from the reflected glory of
your people so it's all about
hmm flourish I like to use the line that
your job is walking around with a can of
water in one hand a can of fertilizer in
the other hand
sprinkling on the seeds and watching
them grow you'll get some weeds and you
gotta pull those weeds out so everyone's
not gonna flourish but you've gotta be
thinking about all the time loving to
see your people thrive loving to see
them get promoted it's a real turn-on it
is what management's all about it's
about bringing to people great lives
great futures changing their family's
life that's a turn-on it's a big deal
that's what you're gonna think about I
graduated from University and with a
degree in electrical engineering I
decided to leave that and I went to
Hawaii Hawaii where there was a
traditional Hindu monastery and I lived
as a celibate Hindu monk for ten years
four years ago my vows expired and
instead of going back to Australia I
decided to come to the mainland US and
looked for a place to stay and finally
got to New York City and I thought this
is a perfect place for an ex-monk no
have a better place for the next month
in New York City and one of the reasons
I really chose New York City was because
I felt that here I've learnt all these
wonderful spiritual tools and techniques
to live my life so I should be able to
live in a very energetic dynamic city
and be able to practice it that and I
feel like if I can practice and live it
in a place like New York City then I
feel entitled to travel and share it
with others but you know if I lived on
the little mountaintop in New Mexico and
a little cabin and said you know yeah
practice this meditation then people go
like well it's easy for you you know you
live in a beautiful cabin in a forest
somewhere but now I live in the midst of
wonderful Manhattan and
and my my goal is to strive and put all
these tools into practice every day now
I've got a really special bonus clip
that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the best live
30 questions of the day it's not enough
to just watch a video you have to do
something about it so pull out your
worksheets and if you don't have the
worksheets you can get them for free
using the link in the description below
here we go question number one what does
being a great leader of mean to you
number two how can you create a better
work environment for you and your team
and number three how can you serve
someone on your team today and if you're
doing the best live 30 challenge with me
I want to celebrate you give me a
hashtag best live 30 down in the
comments below if you want to do
something great then you're gonna need
to build a team whether it's in business
whether it's some other movement that
you want to build if you want to do
something great you can't do it alone
you need a team and so many people go
through this as they're building their
business often they hire the wrong
person at the start and it doesn't work
out and they say you know what forget
this I'm just gonna go back to doing
everything myself and that is not the
answer the answer is to learn how to be
a better leader as your organization
gets bigger and bigger and bigger and
bigger your role the contribution you're
giving actually diminishes if you had a
hundred people in your company the thing
that you're doing day in and day out is
minor compared to what your hundred of
the people are doing for you you know
when you're solo you're doing everything
when you bring on one person maybe
you're doing still 75 percent of the
value because you're the best at what
you do but then as you start bringing
more people on your contribution
diminishes and so yes you're focusing on
what you can become the best in the
world at but your greatest contribution
is going to be leading your team to help
unlock their potential and allowing them
to be the best in the world of what they
do and we don't go to school for
leadership right we don't really learn
leadership in high school we don't learn
leadership in universities of course you
can take maybe you join a sports team
and maybe you had a coach who was
amazing who guided you but this isn't
part of the process for most people
those people aren't training in
leadership this is where I think
understanding your one word is really
important when you know what it is that
you stand for then it's way easier to
a group of people it's way easier to
build a team of people who are aligned
with what you're trying to do
I believe great leadership is about
unlocking the potential and the people
on your team they're working on a
certain standard which may already be
high but you see them being able to work
up here and your job is to help them
close that gap through believing in them
through pushing them through training
them you have to help them close that
gap that's what I believe a great leader
does and the way to do it the easiest
way my experience is through
understanding their one word in their
credo understanding what drives them
they are giving you the tools to help
push them so for example somebody really
values creativity versus somebody who
really values grit hardwork and grit
versus creativity those don't have to be
opposites but it's something that they
really value and so yes we have
organizational goals here's what we're
trying to reach right I want to help
entrepreneurs I want to get to a million
subscribers that's our next goal
we're aligned around that but the people
on my team how do we go in the
accomplish it if somebody really values
creativity that I need to push them on
creativity I need more creative
solutions
I need creative editing I need creative
videography in other words I need
creative thumbnails I need I need to I
need more creativity where somebody's
word is grit or it's part of their credo
is grit that I need them to work harder
I need them to push themselves if
somebody's word is extraordinary that
how can we make this more extraordinary
what do we need to do and you
extraordinary some nails and
extraordinary videography and I need
extraordinary editing I can't make
somebody who values creativity and push
them to extraordinary it's just on who
they are it's gonna be a it's gonna be a
disconnect so understanding what our
goal is having a common goal and then
giving people the flexibility and
freedom to go and help you accomplish
that goal in the way that best suits
them and you understanding them there
one word their credo they're giving you
the tools to push them to giving you the
tools that close that gap between where
the right now or where the potential is
which in my view is the ultimate goal of
a leader if you want to join the best
like 30 challenge click the link right
here
below me or if you want more videos on
how to be an effective leader check the
playlist right there next to me continue
to believe and see you there